i grew up in a house man my dad was the
type of dude
he who gives zero [ __ ] my dad
my dad did anybody else's that my dad
would like to poop with the door open
anybody else hey let me tell you
something you pooping the door open that
is a [ __ ] power move
is that what you do yeah no if you open
the door open you're like this is
my house do you share with the door open
yeah
yeah because when you're basically
telling everybody watch me poop
so my dad and i'm going to ask you this
question after
my dad this is so one time he was
i had a friend over gary miles and gary
was over and we're having a good time
and i hear my dad go
boys boys come in here come in here
and uh he was in his room
so we walked into his room and he wasn't
there he was like in here and i was like
oh no
we turn the corner and he's sitting on
the [ __ ] like this
and he goes just like this what are you
guys doing today and i was like oh my
my friend was just like this
[Music]
[Music]
you